when I was seven my parents joined a
cult I was in a cult I was born into a
cult I was a part of the Advanced
Training Institute from the time I was
seven to the time I was 17 I was part of
the unification church for the first 18
years of my life I joined one taste in
2012 and so 2014 unification Church is a
religious movement that was founded by a
Korean man named Sun Myung Moon in the
50s one taste is an organization that
teaches health and wellness mainly
around sexuality so the Advanced
Training Institute is a fundamentalist
Christian sect that has seminars and a
homeschool curriculum and their central
beliefs are that men are ordained to be
superior over women that birth control
is evil that your father should choose
your husband that music and television
and books are corrupting influences so I
wasn't allowed to partake in any of
those Reverend moon said that Jesus came
to him and wanted reverend moon to
continue a mission that he failed by
being crucified the point of the mission
is to unify the world through
international marriages creating a
global family under God so their
business teachers on the cult orgasmic
meditation which is a sexual practice
that typically in a man and a woman do
together to sensitize their bodies
they're very anti school and anti
college so for a long time I had what
was the equivalent of a second grade
education since that was the last year
that I went to school they believe that
God places men and authority over women
and so a woman has to obey either her
father or her husband without question
and so if you if your husband says I
want to have sex with you tonight if you
say no that's you're saying no to God
mainly the own practice is the thing
orgasmic meditation is a fifteen-minute
partner practice than where a man
typically strokes a woman's clitoris in
the upper-left-hand quad
for 15 minutes this is a specific
container there's ten steps and it's
done exactly the same every time my mom
was a teenager when she met a member of
the cult and my dad was in his early 20s
they were both looking for you know a
purpose a spiritual purpose and looking
to find God as I saw the founders TED
talk in 2007 I was in college I watched
a lot of TED talks I thought it was
amazing my parents became Christians
when I was seven years old and they
started homeschooling me and my brother
and we began attending a local church in
which all the families homeschooled
their children and it turns out that
everybody in this church were members of
the Advanced Training Institute which is
how we got pulled into it
they found her when she was 18 and just
was like we have this community of
people that you know want to give our
lives to this man Reverend moon and to
God essentially my dad was similar he
was like in a commune before like a
hippie commune before he met a member of
the church and then decided to give his
life to the church as well it just gone
through a breakup I just stopped doing
drugs I was kind of just like in a
millennial existential crisis for lack
of a better term I went to one of their
intro meetings hoping to learn like some
sex tips and like my mind was completely
blown by the level of emotional
vulnerability
he wrote a continuation essentially of
the Bible called the Divine Principle so
we read a lot of that like in the
morning and at night before bed my life
was get up at 7 strokes and women's
genitals do yoga and meditate clean the
house because it's like a spiritual
cleansing I wasn't allowed to go to
school I wasn't allowed to have friends
to play with children that weren't a
member of our church wasn't allowed to
watch movies or listen to music you did
a lot of tithing like 30 percent of your
income was supposed to go to the church
the intra chorus at the time I think it
was a hundred bucks it might be 150 or
200 bucks they have a coaching program
which was like the first big purchase
that like forced me to make a huge
decision that was 15,000 arranged
marriages which is probably the most
well known in the unification church
mass weddings basically the homeschool
curriculum was fake news so it taught
that the earth is 6,000 years old it
taught that you know women should obey
their husbands that they would make
people spend money they didn't have and
make it seem normal or like beg borrow
steal to pay this amount it's like the
way it's set up you can't save money
they actually make it so that like
everyone who stays broke which is just
like a way that they keep you trapped
sick you spend all your money there so
you can't leave because like they're the
only place that'll like let you live in
a cool apartment in New York for cheap
it's very restrictive it's like it's we
isolate ourselves from the world because
we're afraid of it in an ohm circle you
have anywhere from two to three hundred
people performing orgasmic meditation
there'd be 15 minutes where I usually a
man was stroked a woman who'd be on a
timer and then after the first 15
minutes he'd switch partners my dad
would go to work and my brother would go
to work and I would just sit there by
myself and go over the homeschool
materials all day and so I never talked
to anybody unless I went to church on
Sunday which of course kind of makes you
more into the beliefs because it's like
your entire social world becomes tied to
other people who believe this the
Moonies would go to college campuses and
try and recruit all these kind of
impressionable young open-minded people
that wanted answers and then they come
with answers you know the Marines had
all the answers like Reverend moon made
this new scripture new doctrine where
you can live your life according to this
and you'll find God and go to heaven and
you'll be a perfect person I think a lot
of people are very afraid I think people
have been afraid for a while I mean I
think over the last 50 years there's
been a lot of social changes in the
country progressive values that
frightened people
from small towns and I think
compassionately there's been a lot of
economic devastation in the south and I
think that that's made people very
vulnerable to falling prey to people who
want to take advantage of them because
they're suffering and you felt like
you're a part of something and something
big and you're important and that was
really attractive to a lot of people at
that time
unlike other cults one taste doesn't
have like super formal structure it's
not like Scientology where there's
rankings or like you have to do this at
this time they influence your perception
of reality which makes you just perceive
the world differently like you shift
your reference screw from like society
to this small group of people that do
these weird sexual things that you now
see as normal it was just more gradual I
became you know an adult and realized
that I can live a life that doesn't
involve the church and I would rather do
that than be a part of it as I got older
I started to really fear the life that
was being set up for me basically my
entire life would be having children
homeschooling them staying home obeying
my husband having sex with him anytime
he wanted never being able to use birth
control so you'd never stop and I just
wanted so much more out of my life than
that I got a message from one of the
executives of the team basically saying
like we only want you if you're willing
to commit your life to us and I was just
like I'm not gonna do that so here's my
limit basically I just left my grandma
had bought me a little car and I used
that to leave home my mom felt her world
was like crumbling everything she worked
for didn't matter anymore because her
child decided to like just throw it out
the window
I went from living with 15 to 25 of my
best friends and I went straight from
that to living in a one-bedroom leaving
the church really created like a
permanent chasm between me and my
parents and me and all of the people
that I grew up with and it's the thing
that's been a very real sadness for me
it was really a shock like I was super
lonely for like two months I was kind of
marked as sinful and as a bad person
after I left it's definitely been for
the better I feel like I'm my own person
and I'm able to live the life that I
want to live and not feel bad about that
I really like my life now I got to know
myself we have to learn how to read
people really well compared to other
people like I didn't really suffer too
many damages my life couldn't be any
different now that it was dead the cool
thing about what I've been through is
that it makes me appreciate the small
things even more you know if I go out
and have a glass of wine with a
girlfriend that's not something I was
supposed to ever be allowed to do and so
even that that tiny little thing feels
like a enormous gift to me you're a
strong person and you don't need to find
answers in another person that's claimed
to have all the answers go out and meet
some other people go spend time by
yourself and realize what you actually
want to do with your time because no one
knows better than you do what's best for
your own development or life there's
always hope there's always a chance to
change your life and if you make a
choice to make your life better the way
that I did it's always worth it